HEY how's it going bros
My name is PewwwDieeePieee
*moment of silence*
Anyway, thanks for watching this video
Please do leave a like if you enjoyed.
It would really help out a lot.
adgdkfhfk It helps my channel out a lot when you leave a like.
Uh
ALSO
Don't forget to check out. I'm doing a
giveaway. So first link in the
description, I'm doing an Amazon giveaway.
It only lasts for 20 seconds, so be sure
that you check it out right now.
Make sure that you also follow me on all my
other social media. Twitter, Facebook,
Instagram, Snapchat, Tumblr, Myspace
Minecraft. I'm also uploading videos on
dailymotion right now. It's basically uh
just videos of me crying
TOP OF THE MORNIN' TO YA
laddies my nama JEEF shout out to all
my other YouTube channels youtube.com/poodiepey
my other YouTube channels youtube.com slash pewdiepie
youtube.com/Pewdie (the better one)
Youtube.com slash pewdie
And of course, youtube.com slash jacksepticeye 2
and of course youtube.com/Jackspedicey2
I'm also starting an adoption program
where you can adopt my baby if you like
this video five times with your left
thumb. As you can tell I have my baby
right here and you can win this baby.
Remember just 5 times left thumb like all
my videos. Also if you tell your mom's
best friend's dog about my channel you
get a chance to fly in here from
wherever in the world. You have to pay
for it yourself though and you get to
stay with me. Outside the office and
don't fucking go near me and also if
this video gets at least 50,000 shares
and likes I will upload a video again
tomorrow. Also you can join my discord
server. For a grand total of two thousand
and eight hundred dollars you can become
a mod on my discord server. We like to
talk about what we thought about
PewDiePie and how he's running outta- out of
ideas.
I prefer pretty  2016 that's the
kind of stuff we get into. It's a good
author too bad it just expired
I'm sorry too slow bitch better luck
next time, but don't you worry.
you like fidget spinners I'm getting a no
but that's okay
I have a fidget spinner you can buy it
right now. It's not a joke. You can buy it.
I recommend buying at least 600 of them.
because
you never know when they run out and you
always need more fidget spinners think
about it, the end of the world is coming
what do you need? Fidgets spinners. I
really mean a lot to me if you guys
check out all my fidget spinners. If you
buy one now, you get one. Also guys if
you haven't checked out already, I'm
starting a book club. It's going to be
here in Brighton. We're going to talk
about some of our favorite literature.
I really recommend "Everyone poops". It's a
fine piece of art that, uh, we're going to
discuss. We meet underneath the Brighton
Pier every Wednesday at 3 a.m.
Also don't of course forget to subscribe.
Have you subscribe to this channel yet?
It really mean a lot to me if you guys
do that. Also check out the bell button
Hit that bell button. I don't know what
the fuck it does but uh please hit the
bell button. Hit - hit the bell button. Hit the
fucking bell button. Why don't you fucking
understand? Hit the bell button! Thank you! Jesus! Follow me on Google+
I don't touch that shit. I don't think
anyone does but please just do that. That
would be great for a chance to win a fidget
spinner and this one is special
because, no reason, no reason. Download
all my apps.
I got "Tuber Simulator", "Legend of the
Brofist", "Pewdiebot". Download them all and
if you download them all and leave a
review saying "Hillary Clinton", you get a
chance to win Hillary Clinton. That's
right.
I got hook ups. She's going to meet up,
with you. Hillary Clinton, everyone, and
also in the next election, if you vote
Hillary Clinton, you get Hillary Clinton
as a president everyone. It's a limited
offer. 20/20. Think about it. We're
not stopping there. Leave a like on my
comment on jacksepticeye's video for no
reason. No reason at all! Have you guys
seen my Pornhub account?
I got Pornhub. I got YouPorn. I got
Redtube. I got Youtube Red... No, I... Ugh!
DON'T FORGET TO CHECK OUT MY SPOTIFY PLAYLIST! IT'S FUCKING LIT AS SHIT, DAWG!
I got all the tracks. Have I told you
I've got a mixtape?! Let's listen to that
shit. 'Welcome to my mind. We are mining
diamonds. We are not a strand mine'
Fuck yeah! DO YOU BREATHE ON A REGULAR BASIS?!
Well if you like this comment, you
could die a premature death. It could
happen at any moment!
Are you dead yet? I don't knooooww!
If you watch ALL my videos, you will cure my
depression! Post this video on every
subreddit ever for a chance to become a
seagull!
Do you like seagulls?! Well you are one
nooow. Tell your favorite teacher about all
my videos and you get a chance to get
molested. Also guys I'm going on tour
with Tana Mongeau! It's gonna be so fucking
good! Oh, you thought it was over?!
Have you seen my Roblox thread. It is
fucking awesome. We're discussing all
kinds of crazy shit. My god you haven't
lived. Have you seen my Instagram meme
page? It's the fucking best Instagram meme
page and my Minecraft... server... AH! You know
I think that was it. Also uhhh check out my
other videos. I'll, uh, I'll leave 'em here. And uh... *shows his hand*
Yeah just- just check 'em out. *Snorts and hocks a loogie* Ch-Check- uh
I feel like my nipples are a little bit too exposed. But yeah, do check out, these vid- this video.
*Burps* *Silence* What are you lookin' at? Come on. Check out...
*the hand fades away* Ch- Check out the other video
Edgar, tell 'em. 'Go check out the video'.
*points at the greenscreen*
What are you doing here? Go check out the other video
After you've done all the thing I asked you though. I leave- I left it all in the description.
*points his hand at the screen once again*
This is extremely boring. *Chuckles*  Like... Just check- Just che- Check the video. Please.
I know you're waiting for me to say something funny. It's not gonna happen. It's ov- The video is done.
Just GO!
You're not- You're not listening. What the fuck is wrong with-
I'm literally holding Edgar just to cover up my nips.
Realize- It's pretty hot in here. They look a bit bigger than they should.
Don't you think? I- I feel like I have good nips. They look a bit weird.
They look a bit freakish, like Jacksepticeye's nips you know? No offense to Jacksepticeye.
I've seen his nips and they're not attractive. What do you think Edgar?
*SIlence* He agrees 100%
Alright, I got bored, so I'm gonna loop myself so it seems like...
Seems like I'm here but I'm not
Has it been ten minutes yet? How long...
Oh there's no way... Okay I'm just gonna loop myself.
(Why are we still here?)
(Just to suffer?)
(Every night, I can feel my leg...)
(and my arm...)
(even my fingers.)
(The body I've lost...)
(the comrades I've lost...)
(won't stop hurting...)
(It's like they're all still there.)
(You feel it, too, don't you?)
( I'm gonna make them give back our past.)
(So) (How's your day going?) (What's new?)
(How bout dat promotion eh?)
(I actually thought this wasn't a loop)
Alright guys, thanks for watc- Thanks
(Congrats, you have wasted 10 mins of your life. Mission accomplished)